immense déconcertante Los Angeles ne se
donne pas au premier venu il y a bien
quelques repères mais pas de
centre-ville pas de quartier historique
la ville s'étend sur près de 100 km
entouré de montagne bordé par le
Pacifique
vu du sol ce n'est qu'une immense zone
résidentielle vide en espagnol Los
Angeles signifient les anges mais où
sont-ils nous les avons trouvé là sur
les autoroutes saturées du vendredi soir
dans leur berline climatisé 3 anges
parmi 10 millions d'anonymes ont bien
voulu être nos guides le temps d'un
weekend
Cathy actrice de Malibu le quartier chic
nous invitait dans son paradis pour
riche avec tourage étudiant iranien
symbole de cette ville au 140
nationalités nous avons vécu au rythme
de sa communauté
et Nana scénariste et Jerry exubérante
nous a entraîné dans le Los Angeles
chacun dans leur monde ils nous ont
montré le vrai visage de leur ville
partons en weekend dans la cité des
anges
[Musique]
nana est arrivé du Ghana à l'âge de 14
ans 15 ans plus tard elle a son petit
appartement à deux pas de l'océan et
elle est sur le point de réaliser son
premier film l'histoire d'une fillette
africaine qui rêve d'Amérique un
scénario autobiographique
ça c'est la chanteuse Grace Jones mon
deuxième film sera sur elle
pendant la semaine nana écrit son
scénario le weekend elle se métamorphose
avant de sortir
si vous regardez des images des années
20 jusqu'au début des années glamour en
1940 vous verrez que les femmes noires
se lissent les cheveux avec des produits
chimiques
moins en tant que femme d'origine
africaine aux États-Unis je veux assumer
mon identité montrer fièrement qui je
suis une femme noire
nana c'est la diva de Venice le quartier
touristique de Los Angeles en bord de
mer
sans se soucier des regards il se lâche
face au Pacifique
dans ce lieu excentrique nana la
celariste trouve l'inspiration
[Musique]
j'adore cet endroit la mère le sable le
ciel
j'ai tous mes amis ici c'est chez moi
je ne viens pas ici pour le spectacle je
viens ici pour rencontrer des
personnages nourrir mon imagination je
m'inspire de la vie
Venise Beach c'est le haut niveau des
anonymes ils viennent se faire remarquer
ou simplement gagner leur vie en
cultivant parfois l'art de l'absurde
moi je gagne bien ma vie 50 € par jour
50 € avec des coups de pied
aux fesses
et toi ça te tente
1 dollar pour me botter le derrière
un coup de pied latéral pas trop fort
allez c'est parti
et voilà
nana s'est trouvé une famille ici parmi
cette communauté d'amuseur de rue
depuis les années 60 le quartier de
Vénus est le berceau de
l'anticonformisme aux États-Unis il a vu
naître des cours en musicaux des Beach
Boys plus grand groupe de rap c'est
aussi la que le skateboard a été inventé
dans les années 70
le samedi les artistes viennent t'y
tester leur spectacle
ses ados de Sao Sandra le quartier des
gangs de Los Angeles on fait le trajet
jusqu'à Venise pour un combat de danse
ils sont les précurseurs d'une nouvelle
mode le jerking mélange de hip-hop et de
techno qui est en train de se répandre à
travers le monde
c'est toi que je voulais leur présenter
et boum je tombe sur toi
alors que j'ai l'air d'une folle
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nana a réalisé son rêve elle
fait du cinéma mais elle revient chaque
weekend auprès de ceux qui l'ont
accueilli quand elle n'avait rien
j'aimerais que les jeunes femmes noires
qui me voient se disent qu'elles aussi
peuvent être libres
ne pas coller au cliché de ce qu'une
femme noire et censée être
ma coupe de cheveux mon skateboard
j'espère que ça ça les inspire que ça
les aide à penser qu'elles peuvent être
elles-mêmes
moi j'ai puisé mon identité ici auprès
de tous ces gens
c'est ici que je me suis vraiment trouvé
dans cette ville immense tout est
histoire de communauté sociale ethnique
culturelle se regrouper avec ses
semblables est une question de survie
première porte d'entrée des États-Unis
c'est une ville d'immigration les
Hispaniques représentent la moitié de la
population à eux seuls le reste de la
ville c'est le monde en miniature petite
Corée petit Tokyo jusqu'à la petite
Éthiopie ou téhérange je laisse le
quartier iranien
[Musique]
ok désolé c'est pourtant bien ici qu'on
avait rendez-vous
entre la tante bleue et le lac qui est
là
alors où sont-ils
après-midi courage étudiant originaire
de Téhéran est perdu au milieu d'un
pique-nique géant
20 milli Rania rassemblés dans un parc
pour fêter le Nouvel An Perse
bon vous êtes où les gars
c'est une fête traditionnelle
chacun vient avec ses amis et avec les
membres de sa famille c'est dur de
rester avec ses copains parce qu'ils
doivent toujours s'échapper pour passer
un peu de temps avec leurs parents
oui plein mais je vais faire de mon
mieux pour les retrouver
le pique-nique et le barbecue font
partie des occupations préférées des
habitants de Los Angeles ce weekend
aujourd'hui ils sont le prétexte pour
une impressionnante démonstration
communautaire
salut mec
à Los Angeles les jeunes Iraniens ont
une réputation de gentil flambeur ils
ont adopté tous les codes vestimentaires
locaux le côté frime de la ville
[Musique]
et rappelle-moi ton nom toi
les filles ont beaucoup de pouvoir au
sein de notre communauté
on ira on ne pourrait pas être ensemble
comme ça fille et garçon
côté
les flics seraient là à surveiller que
je ne suis pas avec une fille c'est
interdit quand on est pas marié on ne
pourrait pas être les uns avec les
autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à Los Angeles les Iraniennes ne se
cachent pas elle se déchaîne même devant
Andy madadian un héros de la
contestation exilé aux États-Unis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'Iran avec la liberté
c'est l'Iran que nous voulons et pour
lequel tous les Iraniens se battent en
ce moment
à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur du pays
dans le monde entier
un million d'Iraniens vivent à Los
Angeles c'est la plus importante
communauté Perse en exil les premiers
sont arrivés après la chute du chat en
1979 et cela ne s'est jamais arrêté
demain une autre communauté de Los
Angeles fera la fête dans ce parc
les acteurs changent mais le décor reste
le même Los Angeles terre d'exil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres au nord en
longeant le Pacifique il est un quartier
de la ville où ni nana ni tourage ne
pourront aller passer le weekend
vous êtes invité à déjeuner
ici il faut montrer patte blanche sans
invitation nous n'aurions pu entrer à
Paradise Cove la baie du Paradis 300
résidences secondaires sur une falaise
un petit millier de privilégiés qui
surplombe une plage privée un bout
d'Océan pour eux seuls
Cathy 38 ans ancienne actrice s'y amuse
beaucoup elle n'a pas d'enfant un
caniche qui ne la quitte jamais son mari
travaille à 500 km de Los Angeles elle
passe ce weekend ici depuis 8 ans
[Musique]
cette maison là c'est celle de Pamela
Anderson
la Maison Blanche là c'est la sienne je
dis pas trop fort parce qu'elle est
terrorisée à l'idée que quelqu'un
débarque chez elle
acteur producteur les riches célèbres
ont jeté leur dévolu sur ce quartier de
mobil-home ici ils ont l'impression de
renouer avec l'esprit de bohème et
hippie des années 70 même si leur petite
cabane coûte au moins 2 millions d'euros
je qualifierais cet endroit de détendu
amusant et chaleureux aussi
oh mon dieu mais vous êtes entassés à
combien sur cette voiture de golf
tu as vu ces gamins au volant de la
voiture
il roule comme des dingues
oui ce sont des nouveaux qui sont-ils
Cathy et John qui vient d'emménager ils
ont invité des amis
bon je vais envoyer un avertissement
pour leur dire de ralentir oui ils sont
incontrôlables je suis filmé
les habitants de Paradise Cove peuvent
profiter d'une plage déserte loin du
tumulte de Vénus Beach
une voisine de Cathy depuis quelques
semaines de l'initier au paddle surf un
nouveau sport très à la mode depuis 2
ans Californie
une planche une rame une sorte de surf
détournée moins physique quoique
ah c'était vraiment instable j'ai failli
me noyer
mon dieu
et en plus on a des requins ici des
Grands Blancs juste au large de cette
côte ils sont là
elle ne veut pas le reconnaître mais ils
sont bien là
oui ils sont là
ils ne sont pas là pour nous faire mal
c'est juste leur territoire
rapide retour à la maison en voiture de
golf toujours dans 2h cathy est invité
chez des voisins un dîner entre amis
comme tous les samedis appareil
[Applaudissements]
s
[Musique]
très seul
j'ai vraiment besoin d'avoir un groupe
un esprit de communauté
et je pense que c'est la même chose pour
tout le monde à Los Angeles parce que la
plupart des habitants de cette ville
viennent d'ailleurs
ce sont des étrangers donc ils ont tous
besoin d'un cercle d'amis
de se constituer vite un groupe de gens
avec qui il se sent à l'aise
les communautés se trouvent parfois là
où on ne les attend pas
derrière la plage de paradiseco fermé au
public
des dizaines de surfeurs attendent le
meilleur moment pour s'élancer sur une
des plus belles vagues au monde celle de
Malibu là aussi nous avons vu que tout
était histoire de groupe les surfeurs
noirs se retrouvent ici une fois par
mois pour prendre les vagues ensemble il
y a 50 ans autant de la ségrégation les
habitants noirs de Los Angeles étaient
autorisé que sur une seule plage à 20 km
de là aujourd'hui ils sont encore peu
nombreux mais tiennent à se faire voir
on a formé un groupe de personnes qui
veulent sortir de leur carcans comment
ça
et bien tous les clichés sur le surfeur
qui doit forcément être un mec blond aux
yeux bleus le surfeur type quoi
il faut casser tous ces stéréotypes
ou les absorber il est un cliché que
toutes les communautés de Los Angeles
partagent c'est celui du culte du corps
et le weekend c'est le moment idéal pour
l'observer
[Musique]
nana ne fais pas exception à la règle le
weekend après son tour à Venise Beach
elle sera au Gold gym salut tu vas bien
un endroit surnommé ici la Mecque du
fitness
12000 abonnés la salle est ouverte de 4h
du matin à minuit
Schwarzenegger aujourd'hui gouverneur de
Californie il y a sculpté ses muscles
légendaires
homme-femme de tous âges couleur et
profession se retrouve nuit et jour dans
ce lieu clos à Los Angeles rajeunir son
corps et parfois son visage est entré
dans les mœurs la mode du fitness est né
ici elle aussi
il y a des gens qui viennent ici deux
fois par jour on est plus sportif à Los
Angeles qu'ailleurs à cause de
l'industrie du cinéma et puis le temps
est plus beau qu'à New York les gens ne
se cachent pas derrière leurs vêtements
[Musique]
c'est superficiel c'est un cliché mais
cela repose sur l'histoire de Los
Angeles et du cinéma
les gens ont toujours eu le culte de
leur image ici
dans les professions artistiques de Los
Angeles c'est très simple ce qui compte
c'est la première impression que vous
faites
[Musique]
Los Angeles et l'une des villes
américaines qui compte le moins de cas
d'obésité il faut rester dans la course
à la gloire ne pas ternir le rêve
et même entretenir le rêve
comme tourage qui a 28 ans ne sort
jamais sans sa Porsche sa famille est
venue chercher à Los Angeles la liberté
ils ne sont pas des immigrés économiques
et tiennent à le montrer épouser la
réussite américaine et garder ses
traditions pour tourage je n'irai rien
entre deux cultures tout est histoire
d'équilibre
voilà ma mère à son mariage il y a 30
ans ça c'est moi et j'ai la coupe de
cheveux qu'elle préfère
j'aimerais me faire tatouer tout le
corps mais ils ne veulent pas
dès que je n'habiterai plus chez mes
parents je me ferai faire un piercing
ils seront pas contents pour eux tout ce
qui est accessoire et mal
tu vis dans une communauté Perse tu ne
peux pas faire ça
alors maman ça te plaît tu approuves je
leur ai bien expliqué ici il faut passer
l'examen avoir de l'allure
tu es toujours beau
mon père avait une vie très confortable
en Iran il avait plusieurs
usines ma mère aussi avait tout ce
qu'elle voulait mais pour eux le rêve
américain c'était la réussite de leur
enfant
chaque samedi en fin d'après-midi il se
fait coiffer par sa mère entre eux il
parle persan
une belle maman un beau gosse
cathy est en retard à son cocktail on
aurait dû prendre une voiture de golf
celui qui nous reçoit habite juste
derrière cette maison
ambiance détendue nous sommes très bien
accueillis chez les hippie chic comme il
se définit ce même les bourgeois bohème
de Los Angeles
Margarita grand vin européen champagne
pour accueillir de nouveaux résidents
là où vous habitiez avant est-ce que
vous aviez un groupe aussi soudé que le
nôtre
oui mais la différence c'est qu'ici on
habite tellement proche les uns des
autres que sans faire d'effort on
rencontre les voisins tous les jours
et parfois c'est électrique avec les
voisins
mon voisin Paul c'est un ancien
détective je le connais depuis une
semaine ou deux et il rentre en peignoir
dans ma maison sans frapper il s'assoit
et il allume sa pipe
c'est vrai qu'ici dès que tu tires la
chasse d'eau tout le monde est au
courant
les adultes à l'apéritif les enfants au
billard la vie comme un long fleuve
tranquille mais l'alcool est dans
Margarita et champagne mélangées
eux-même commencent les voir plus clair
cette vie à Los Angeles est-ce vraiment
la vraie vie
vous savez quoi je suis en train de
réaliser qu'ici tout le monde est blanc
tout le monde est riche et quand vous
regardez tout ça de près il y a pas de
non aucune
si il y a des Mercedes
oui des Range Rover des voitures
allemandes des anglaises
ici la diversité vient des gens qui
nettoient et des jardiniers
remise en cause ou conscience de classe
la discussion s'achèvera très tard dans
la nuit
[Rires]
[Musique]
à Los Angeles ce weekend rien n'est
donné à l'étranger de passage les
avenues sont toujours aussi désertes ce
samedi soir nana travaillera toute la
nuit sur son scénario dans son
appartement
courage lui fêtera son anniversaire dans
une boîte de nuit en iranien
lui solitaire ou faites entre amis
chacun se replie dans son cocon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à Los Angeles cela vaut la peine de se
réveiller tôt le dimanche matin
quand les vagues embrumé se donne tout
premier surfeur
quand les joggers longe la mer et
traversent la ville encore endormie
à cette heure-là elle se montre sous un
autre visage plus âpre plus vrai
peut-être
Venise la flamboyante appartient alors à
ceux qui n'ont rien
Los Angeles et la ville américaine qui
concentre le plus grand nombre de SDF et
la crise acheté dans la rue des milliers
de sans-abris supplémentaires
à l'aube il se dissipe dans l'immensité
de la ville
ils deviennent des ombres accrochés à
leur chariot et se fonde dans le décor
à Los Angeles le dimanche matin c'est
l'heure des fantômes les soldats morts
au combat sont de ceux-là
il reste des croix par ici vous pouvez
les planter là-bas
depuis 6 ans des volontaires plantes
décroît dans le sable à Santa Monica sur
une des plages les plus populaires de la
ville c'est leur façon de dénoncer les
guerres d'Irak et d'Afghanistan
tu mets ces deux croix l'une à côté de
l'autre j'étais rendu Vietnam d'Irak ou
pacifiste convaincu comme Erin ils ont
imaginé ce mémorial d'un jour ce sont
les noms des soldats américains qui ont
été tués à la guerre
chacune pour un de ses soldats des
hommes et des femmes et tu vois sur ce
panneau ce sont des femmes soldats
uniquement
ils veulent ainsi sensibiliser les
familles et leurs enfants aux
conséquences de la guerre
tu vois tous ces noms et Léonore Ashley
Jennifer
pourquoi montrez-vous ça a une petite
fille comme elle
parce que les recruteurs de l'armée de
terre de la marine de l'Armée de l'Air
vont venir dans son école à la cantine
dans les couloirs dans les centres
commerciaux devant les cinémas et quand
elle sera adolescente si ça ne marche
pas bien pour elle à l'école qu'elle ne
trouve pas de travail la tentation sera
forte de partir au front
depuis la guerre du Vietnam Los Angeles
est à l'avant-garde de la contestation
pacifiste en quelques heures la plage se
transforme en une tribune citoyenne sous
les yeux des promeneurs qui le dimanche
viennent par centaines s'amuser sur le
ponton de Santa Monica un parc
d'attraction sur la mer
tourage aime revenir avec ses amis à cet
endroit
c'est là qu'il a découvert la ville
quand il est arrivé avec ses parents
duo de la grande roue il était enfant
émerveillé aujourd'hui il est toujours
même si la réalité a rattrapé le conte
de fée
il y a tellement de choses à faire ici
que vous pouvez passer votre temps à
vous amuser mais il faut garder les
pieds sur terre travailler sans trop
laisser se distraire parce que si vous
avez les moyens vous pouvez passer la
journée de 8h du matin à 3h le lendemain
à vous faire plaisir
vous ne vous ennuierez jamais mais ça
vous coûtera beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
le weekend s'achève la plage se vide
tout devient calme subitement
mais un peu plus loin une joyeuse
cacophonie attire notre attention
c'est le concert de tambour du dimanche
soir
une fois par semaine des dizaines de
percussions résonnent sur la plage de
Santa Monica
et Nana n'oublie jamais de s'y rendre
pour vivre à Los Angeles parce qu'il
faut créer tout le temps ça demande
beaucoup d'énergie tout le monde peut
venir à se rassemblement tout le monde
est bienvenu jeune vieux chrétien homo
hétéro tout Los Angeles et là ce soir
[Musique]
fumer sur la plage alors que d'ordinaire
tout y est interdit même d'y jouer au
ballon
une fois par semaine pourtant la ville
tolère se rassemblement exutoire
surveillé de près
là tout le monde se mélange dans une
sorte de trans qui ne s'arrêtera qu'avec
la nuit
lundi matin les tambours se seront tu
Los Angeles reprendra sa course et
redeviendra une ville américaine comme
une autre